let's go to our next question today hey
David do you think England should get
rid of their monarchy it serves no real
purpose at this point except maybe as a
version of British soft power I have
been speaking out against the monarchy
of England for a very long time I think
it is antiquated I think that it is a
waste of money and I think that it is
reinforcing a system of government that
Western liberal democracy should be
completely opposed to now let's go and
let the bunk myself point by point here
number one the idea that it is a waste
of money the counterpoint is the money
given to the royal family
to provide their lifestyle is made back
and exceeded by the tourism that the
royal family generates okay well what
about giving them a lot less money still
they'd probably still generate the same
amount of tourism wouldn't it yeah and
you'd also still have the relics right
you'd still have Buckingham Palace
absolutely still have Windsor Castle
like people would still visit those
places yes about the history the other
counterpoint to what I said is that even
though it is officially a monarchy that
it's still a Western modern liberal
democracy in the sense that it's really
the Prime Minister and the elected
officials that actually wield the power
and although on paper the Prime Minister
has to consult with the Queen about
certain things that it's completely
symbolic well then get rid of it all the
way because I think that it is in is by
its very existence it is a reference to
and a sort of vestige of a system of
government that I am completely and
fundamentally opposed to which is the
passing down of power on the basis of
who you happen to be born to and you
know what even if you get rid of a
monarchy because class mobility is so
low in places like the United States and
to a lesser degree but still an
important degree that UK you're still
going to basically be passing down power
privilege and wealth by virtue of who
you happen to be born to because that's
the way it works and even in the United
States we still have that if you're born
poor your way like
to stay porn if you're born rich or way
likely to stay rich
you can still pass down power by family
lineage even without having the monarchy
but doesn't everyone like the Queen I
mean she's such an adorable figure she's
been around for so long she's what 90
years old now or so I think you'd have a
better case to make once the power goes
from her to her son to Charles and then
to Wells William no no that at this
point I don't think people are gonna
rush to support them I think at that
point we can start working on getting
rid of the monarchy but I like queen
elizabeth ii too much I got to keep it
for now I think it would be fine to say
wait until the throne is passed before
you try to get rid of it I I wanted out
and I've not heard any compelling
argument for keeping the monarchy in the
United Kingdom I've heard arguments they
have not been compelling to me